we're on problem 20 from 20 of the five
coordinates associated with points a b c
and d e on a b c d and e on the number
line above which has the greatest
absolute value okay so they just let me
just draw the number line that they drew
so and they say from 0 to 1 so 0 1 2 and
they say minus 1 minus 2 and then they
say these are choices a B C D and E
which of the five coordinates associated
with the points a B C D and E on the
number line above which has the greatest
absolute value so you can view absolute
value is the distance from zero so the
greatest distance from zero is going to
happen in two places it's going to
happen here at a it's also going to
happen here at E can you have more than
one right answer because both of those
are choices let's see all the figures
are except one is stated in a specific
problem all figures saw and indicate the
best of the answer choices given let me
see can you have I'm looking up the
thing is it possible to have more than
one right answer because it doesn't seem
this doesn't seem quite right that I can
have two possible answers for this one
the answer is a the coordinate a is the
farthest from zero this has the greatest
absolute value I just agree with that it
could be choice E as well the coordinate
the absolute value of the number X is a
distance between X and 0 on the number
line the coordinate of point a is a
farther from 0 and that has the greatest
absolute value that's false well I mean
that's true
but E is just as far I don't know I
think they made a mistake I think this
could be choices a or E because the
absolute value of either of those is 2 I
think they made a mistake and they say
the choice is a which I agree with but
it could just as easily be choice E so I
don't know write a letter to GMAC
I mean this seems pretty straightforward
of the five coordinates associated with
choices ABCDE and the number line which
has the greatest absolute value absolute
value at this point is to the absolute
value of this point is two they're equal
anyway next problem so I think it should
be a or E it's surprising that they
would let a question like that get
through their screen or at least they
should get rid of choice E if x and y
are prime numbers so x and y are prime
which of the following cannot be the sum
of x and y X plus y cannot equal not
equal what so statement one five well I
can immediately say two plus three is
equal to five so that doesn't work
cannot equal so bb9
I could do two plus seven is equal to
nine so it's not this was a B let's see
what C is so it's not B C is 13 so let
me think what could be eleven plus two
is equal to 13 so it's not choice C D 16
16 the sum so let me see sixteen nine at
seven no 11 + 5 11 plus five is equal to
16 so it's not so without even looking
at e it's probably going to be e e 23
let me see if I can come up with two
prime numbers that add up to 23 19 and
four no let's see two and twenty-one no
I mean first of all we found examples
for all of these so you should if you
don't want to waste time on the GMAT you
should already have chosen EE and moved
on by this point but we could just look
through a bunch of a bunch of prime
numbers and think of if we can if they
can add up to 23 but I can't think of
any right the moment and I feel pretty
good that E is the answer because I was
able to find prime numbers that add it
up to all the other four choices next
question 22 and I will switch colors
just to ease the monotony if each of the
following fractions were written as a
repeating decimal which hat which would
have the longest sequence of different
digits the longest sequence of different
days are they going to sit here and make
us
so let me write all the choices down
maybe we can do some cancellation from
the get-go to over 11 B is 1/3 and we
already know that that's going to be one
that's just going to be 0.33 repeating
longest sequence of different digits so
it's not going to be choice B because
choice B it doesn't have different
digits it just keeps being a 3 so it's
not going to be choice B so we don't
have to worry about that choice C 41
over 99 choice D is 2 over 3 we know
that that's 0.666 just keeps going so
it's not going to be that it's the same
digit that just keeps repeating and
choice E is 23 divided by 37 so I think
11 divided 2 2/11 repeats let's just try
it though 11 goes into 2.000
one time 1 times 11 is 11 you get a 90
11 goes into 90 goes into 8 times 88
it's 20 I already see the pattern 11
goes into 20 2 times 2 times i sadi goes
into 20 one time 1 times 11 is 11 then
you go to 90 goes at 8 times so it's
just point 1 8 1 8 1 8 this is going to
keep repeating point 1 8 so that's 2
over 1141 over 99 let me do it in
different color just so I don't get too
messy 99 goes into 40 one point zero
zero zero zero so 99 goes into 410 four
times four times 99 is what 396 4 times
9 is 6 3 4 times 9 is 36 396 this is
equal to 4 14090 9 goes into 140 one
time one times 99 is 99 this becomes 41
already start repeating right 99 goes
into 410 that's just like that so it's
going to be 0.41 repeating over and over
again because we got the same number
again we're going 99 go to 41 4 times
we're going to get 396 it's just going
to keep happening and they're going to
get
what are we going to get 396 and then
we're going to get 140 again is for one
for one so it's for one repeating so if
I had to guess it's already going to be
choice e without having to do any work
because these just have the same numbers
repeating from the get-go choices a and
C have the same two numbers repeating
from the get-go so they're equivalent
I'm guessing that this one has a lot
more so you could if you just wanted to
worry about time you could just picky
and move on but let's do it just just to
prove to ourselves so 37 goes into 23 I
don't remember when I took the GMAT
having to do this much decimal division
so Ormoc decimal multiplication so 37
goes into 230 I don't know just go into
6 times
no probably 5 times 5 times 7 is 35 5
times 3 is 15 18 plus 3
okay 30 85 actually this would have gone
six times let me change that to six so
let me change it 6 let me do it in a
different color or make too messy 6
times 7 is 42 6 times 3 is 18 plus 4 s 1
is 6 times 3 is 18 plus 22 suppose 80 37
goes into 80 2 times 2 times 37 is what
74 2 times 37 right 60 plus 1474 you get
a 60 13 goes 60 so already we've started
repeating we haven't even started
repeating or already three digits into
it so this one's going to have the most
this is going to have the longest
sequence of different digits so we don't
have to keep going we've answered our
question that choice is definitely e a
next question they've drawn something
there and the figure above the
coordinates of point V are well this is
just kind of a reading the graph type of
problem I'm just going to draw this
fourth quadrant okay just so that we can
show you so I can show you how I think
about it ok so let me just count 1 2 3 4
5
one two three four five so just to you
know they tell us that each of those
slashes are one because they go back you
know they do it a couple places to go
one two three four five and then they
say this is negative five so that's
information that you actually need you
have to know what that each of those
slashes are definitely one but then on
this they go one two three four five six
seven so they go one two three four five
six seven so this is 0.7 and you have to
just count it on your paper this is one
two three four five this is point 1 2 3
4 5 this is minus 5 and this is where V
is so they're just testing to see
whether you can if you know how to you
know graph a point so this is X is 7 and
Y is minus 5 so it's 7 minus 5 and
actually and actually that's interesting
you didn't even know you know hey you
don't even have to count the points
because you can say you know what this
is in the fourth quadrant X is positive
Y is negative and if you look at all the
choices there's only one choice where X
is positive and Y is negative and that's
choice E so you really didn't even have
to count it although I think this
wouldn't have taken much time to count
it so that's not like a huge shortcut
anyway see you in the next video